the og3 what is something that you
didn't get to do in the first movie that
you were so excited to get to do this
time around I got to work with the
actors in the booth in real life and I
didn't get that the first time around
although I do feel like the the talent
that runs through this whole story this
whole film this whole project uh is so
wicked that that even though the first
time around I may not have had them in
the room it was as if they were there uh
with with their reading but there is
nothing like that human interaction yeah
that has to change it up a little bit
yeah shamik last time miles was
struggling with taking his leap of faith
what is he struggling with this time in
the sequel how he's gonna wear that mask
you know but honestly
I think I think it's more about than the
initial you know that feeling when when
you want to be accepted by people or uh
was it validation I think he's seeking
some validation from the spider Society
he feels like he's the ultimate version
of himself if he's able to go through
Dimensions like Gwen or like Peter and
Etc you know he just wants to be
accepted by this Society but as soon as
he figures out like okay you guys are a
little different than me or for whatever
reason it's not that they're bad it's
just perspectives you know my moral
compass is what it is and obviously
everybody else is a little crazy right
now so I'm gonna do what I want to do
and he wears that mask completely at
that point so I think it's the
validation aspect but I think as soon as
he has an understanding of the stakes
he's good he's you know I think one of
the reasons I was I was like sobbing at
the beginning is Haley we get to go into
Gwen's world and it is so beautiful I
heard it described as a mood ring which
I think is like the most perfect way to
describe it how did going into that
world exploring that a little more do
you feel like that informed uh your
perception of the character even more
absolutely absolutely I mean right off
the bat we learn I learned a lot about
her and it's uh it's a lot of
information in a
quick little hit right there off the top
and and then we get to dig deeper into
it so I I was so excited to have the
opportunity to to myself get into that
uh and and learn more about her and
discover things as we went along but
even more than that that the fans the
fans get a little more insight into her
world absolutely and Jake in the first
movie we get to see Peter B Parker going
I don't want to be a dad then he kind of
parent miles and he goes wait do I want
kids and now he has a daughter how is
Peter B Parker the father well I think
he's pretty good I mean he probably
shouldn't bring his daughter on these
missions but you know she might have
something to her but I think for him in
dealing with Miles and getting to know
him he did see that there's something
great about the new generation and there
was something he hadn't seen before and
that is there's something really fun
about watching somebody else take over
and I think realizing that was his idea
of saying maybe I'm ready for this next
step mm-hmm
um this is like you all franchises a
where's Waldo of of talent is there an
actor you would love to see join this
franchise at some point
uh Dennis Franz
from NYPD Blue I would like to see him
come out of retirement I'd like to hear
that Chicago accent in the mask that is
specific I love it
Snoop Dogg
We Gotta Throw like Rihanna in there or
something that'd be great yeah that'd be
great do you ever think about what your
multiversal self would be doing it's
like what if I didn't move to LA what if
I didn't start acting you met your
multiversal self what are they doing
mine is probably designing an app and
really into he's designing the city wow
uh I uh
I don't I don't know what I'd be doing
mine's about 30 pounds Fowler living in
Chicago
what is the quality about each of your
characters that you would
wanted to adopt after doing this role
um I love the whole concept of taking
that leap of faith
um and how we wear the mask really being
like important because I am taking that
with my how I am an actor what that
means whatever impact I have on the
people that have the impact with what I
do with it I really want to um
it's how I'd step in that as shamique
and I really want to leave a lasting
impact on The Human Experience I I do
love that
that a lot of this
experience that she's having and this
journey that she's on is about really
finding her purpose
um and I do feel that she believes a lot
of it has to do with helping people and
and also leaving a lasting positive
impact on on those around her and I who
would love to do the same
I think Peter's finding some optimism
which I think is nice yeah he is he is
he's a slightly different Beauty
slightly different yeah come on go easy
on the kid he had a terrible teacher
Peter miles you have a baby
I'll take it from here